hello citizens of the rejection it's me
Tara Erickson a long time my friends say
your name Andrew it is I oh he said it
interesting but he didn't give his last
name I don't remember oh my goodness we
watch make one together and now we're
gonna watch make two if you haven't seen
me and this guy watch make one you
should go back you should watch it it's
on this channel now listen up you're
gonna leave a like right you're gonna
get on the computer go do some comment
do you say how cool we are and also
don't forget to subscribe and when you
do you'll bring
was a different one did you like it I
loved it everything I switched it up
full length reaction and watch long is
on the patreon so you guys need to
become patrons if you're not already
okay because you can sync up with your
full copy what's the whole thing with me
and him the whole entire thing you sit
there popcorn candy me and him talking
about make two megalodons and 18 abs
two also Greg and John cover several
shows over there exclusively with
reaction highlights and watchalogs
included now are you ready for a
Megalodon because I'm getting Juiced up
I'm already Juiced up I'm so excited
okay megalodons here we go
[Music]
foreign
65 million years ago
ah such as nature works yeah bye bye
little bug and what's gonna eat that
uh
oh yeah
cool
Tyrannosaurus
Tyrannosaurus oh
my God
[Music]
are they like we can take you to your ex
or what no okay they turned around
that's not a good sign oh boy please let
this uh shark jump right if the shark
eats him alive
like what y'all running from
I know I'm scared
[Music]
oh my God yes I am on board I was a nice
tone Setter that was awesome but it
doesn't matter we got Jason Statham
again that shark still doesn't stand a
chance it doesn't matter if it can take
out Tyrannosaurus Rex no it doesn't we
got 18 ABS he's got so many
much
what's the most amount you can do
um 0.5 12. really I can't go past 12 as
of right now I'm not gonna lie I've
never I don't think I've tried to do a
pull up I'll have to get on that
what is going on in here
oh cool said explosive Jill I don't know
I just I just know that word from the
Arkham games thank you Batman
where is he
what oh awesome in a shipping yard on a
boat
why is this man anywhere near water
anymore
he's like dude I took down megalodons I
ain't afraid of the water that's
probably his job now he's like come on
now you people pay me to be out here
because I'm awesome with Megas
oh he snuck aboard okay oh Jason Statham
looks older but he's still hot AF I just
watched him uh in Snatch obviously he's
way younger but he's always been such a
badass yeah
alcohol
I would release the parrot do it offer
him a cracker it worked in Home Alone
three ah well done
I'm here from the home office
that's funny there's no line that's
going to beat that no
oh
ah what's going on oh
okay all right
what are these people doing on this boat
damn I mean we saw them throwing what
looked like oil into the wall oh is that
I missed it I think uh maybe I saw it
but I didn't register because you guys
know how I am
damn
now cool yeah
yeah you get them
that stair jump was awesome
[Music]
into the ocean no you're all under
arrest
Eagle dumping of radioactive material
there you go you want to see the word
it's right in my pocket
does he have a thing yeah he has a thing
in his backpack right you're 200 miles
I'm sure so enjoy your swim
oh nice is that Cliff Curtis yeah cool
it's like a green James Bond James Bond
yeah it is awesome
as we mentioned earlier Dark Knight
esque with the Escape oh yeah
it'd be awesome Define awesome
that's awesome also I feel like he'd get
in there and slam his head as they take
off right into a wall I don't know why
to see how it knocked out but they're
not gonna show us yeah
oh my God damn
okay 21 increasing power only 21 that
guy's breaking cement
is
that really the little girl from the
first one yeah it got a little older so
obviously that's her brother from uh
okay because he said favorite niece the
guy looked familiar to you
no I don't like him you don't like
anyone
I like you that's because I save your
life all the time I buy your beers and I
back you up in bar fights I would like
him too yeah can you be my best friend
right please give a warm welcome to the
director of The Institute
oh from the last movie The Dead
what she died how what happened that's
her mom oh it makes me sad I really
liked her character a lot
what what what what is this yeah what is
this is it real
she is the world's only Megalodon in
captivity why do you have that in
captivity
okay so they have to study yet clearly
they didn't watch deep blue sea thanks
to you we have the ability to go further
than ever before
I'm all for what he just said but do we
have to have that in captivity no I mean
this is movie writing at its best for a
sequel they're like let's just have it
be there and then bad stuff happen who
wants to get a selfie with the man who
fought a Megalodon and lived to tell the
tale we give you ladies and gentlemen
Jonas Taylor
18 ABS yeah I really hope they cut to
them training the shark like uh kill you
doing a whistle and giving it fish he
probably would be like one of the most
famous men in the world yeah
why
oh with the with that suit I guess it's
the Nano yeah yeah
I want to dive the trench no I'm almost
diving all the time at my age not the 25
000 feet
saying is too dangerous uh it's just a
little
in Psychology they call that cognitive
dissonance in the real world they call
it parenting
I like that description you're 14.
exactly
I know every system on model one she's
been fixing ships since she was like
five
minutes
God it's gonna be like Tiki versus human
all over again except with a Megalodon
you hear what he just said he said is
the experiment do I taste good oh yeah I
am all in protein
what you can't bet on a shark man that's
a bad company hey look who's back I'd
like to respectfully suggest that this
is truly a terrible idea mags and
Humanity were never meant to mix yeah he
and I have a special bond oh God every
Sea World trainer Circa 2000 right
what are you doing
oh I kind of want to reach out and pet
it too but also I'm a little scared I
think she's looking at us
she's clocking her dinner for later
tonight yeah seeing what's on the menu
she's coming around
heart rate is up
oh God
yeah dude heart rate is up good luck
buddy she's not responding
200 meters
say bye bye it's too late
what's he gonna do
no did he just eat him oh my God yeah
what what
did you just shoot up because we didn't
see yeah he did something where he was
pulling to the side it was still a dumb
idea in my opinion you are taking bigger
and bigger risks each time you go out I
guess we both know about that the guy
who jumped into the water with the mag
just said you're taking bigger risks
yeah just sand
I think battling something he's just
trying to save the environment yeah I
think battling a few humans is not as
big of a deal yeah
it does it's like we can relate I guess
yeah but not
um
I mean the concept is interesting yeah
many depth that's a little scary
foreign
I still love Jason Statham in this film
he just like he looks a little bored
yeah
yeah but I still love him obviously
I'm still happy that he's here yeah
[Music]
it's like I gotta battle this damn my
key is gonna Escape
my business
yeah I think you're right figuring out
his Escape what is he gonna Ram it I
mean you're probably strong enough let's
do it enough
that quickly you got out
amazing why wouldn't it be stronger I
feel like those would be reinforced a
little bit better but yeah why wouldn't
it be like that's the strong oh my
goodness I figured it would take a
couple of rammings everyone let's get
the show underwater
feet we are exploring area 19. so now
they're gonna be that's gonna be a
conflict for her because it's going to
be a Megalodon she grew up with because
it was a baby Megalodon and now they're
gonna have to battle it I guess ready
for the drop guys
again I'm still always amazing this in
the first one the visuals are always
there yeah so good we're going on a
shark Adventure I'm still with you what
you said in the first one I want to hear
Under the Sea yeah
it's 11 over Mission spec
IES
more like you're a mouth breather
uh oh did you sneak aboard uh oh Jonas
oh crap that's not good I see that
you're angry but I believe that this is
a reasonable and
can I just say
I did all kinds of stupid things when I
was 14. oh my goodness really this is
your 26th trench die without incident
Subs of electric predator
actually
yeah she's smart enough she's like I
thought of everything we've got company
[Music]
a MAG
gie he died flank speed
this was the perfect Trench Run for you
to sneak aboard yeah
impossible just got possible 500 meters
to the thermocline my teeth closing fast
cool be careful
don't worry I'm not gonna break the
pretty toys
feel like you are
it says warning
Ah that's so spooky but cool too she
must have followed our heat signature
that's great she must have escaped how
did that happen that's why you don't
have a pet shark proximity alert Megs
ah she's calling him
[Music]
Dude Looks old and ready to fight like
has been through 17 Wars oh my
oh my goodness did this make anyone's
ever say
terrifying we have to see what they're
up to and what about me
well I thought we'd go if you do not
have any fear kid nah man she grew up
with Mom she's been around Megs her
whole life see anything dangerous
back we're changing the mission profile
I do like that that girl's on her side
because I would be too I'd be like she's
14 whatever
let's explore we're gonna follow some
giant sharks to our unknown sector I'm
with him I'm with him
yeah I don't think they should be
following him but I feel like maybe
she's all right he's the only one who
has logic consent yeah I've seen enough
shark movies to know you don't follow
the where the sharks are but we need to
follow the movie tropes for the action
for entertainment purposes of course I
want them to but
if it were me of course yeah I'm not
gonna have it your mom loves this place
more than anything
I'm glad I finally get to see it
you're grounded for the rest of your
life that's a reasonable response
is some instinctual Gathering
they're here to mate
that's why haichi has been acting
strangely right well thanks
no way
is that a wreck
that's not that from the beginning
is it I don't think so
I
have more airlocks
who would even have the technology
oh is what's his nuts back from the
office
yeah he died in the first movie yeah he
died because he was the money man yeah
well
mind is tough
and steady oh it's that the guy with the
glasses and he said I don't like him
the party okay it's the competition
explosives
to get clear sorry guys what what just
don't do it see that's the difference
oh yep
oh my God I'm gonna have to go through
oh my goodness I was gonna say that's
the difference between him and Jonas
like he did it maliciously where Jonas
had no choice to do it in the first film
right
yeah is that the bad ship I hope so oh
yeah we want him to get in the bad guy
yeah
oh okay good it was
dude you're blowing up underneath the
ocean like what the f
well that's gonna let that's gonna
release them yeah there we go I mean
that's where where was it three Megs
under there yeah
cheese and there might be a birth soon
they were mating yeah well we gotta have
a meg3 so ah
oh boy all right I thought you said I'm
not gonna hurt the toys
oh boy
Whoa that is oh my goodness are they
gonna get buried alive
what if the Megalodon goes after the
things and breaks up the Rock and then
they still live
how's that possible is it her uncle well
how long to fix it it's the control
board Mac there is no fixing it
[Music]
we're losing air fast Rob the power
through the heating cell
I like that they're not just putting
Jason Statham in there to fix it that
it's like the women fixing it and he
kind of hasn't had much to do but like
to the emergency dive suit somewhere
we're gonna need a ride up that's going
to be a problem it's not going to be
possible
oh my goodness
we can't walk oh do they have those
mecco suits or whatever those suits have
two hours here oh see there you go it
will go slow and steady they'll hold
it's three kilometers
you'll be defenseless out there I just
want to see him punched
yeah this is what we got and this is
what we're gonna do yeah we're not just
gonna die down here this is too similar
to that Titanic situation that just
recently happened yeah the filming
happened way before that but still it's
kind of meta yeah oh but they get
weapons the radios won't relate to the
surface so we're going dark
I don't think the uncle would do that I
don't think it was I don't think it was
the uncle I was just like well why was
he like let's push down to go see all
the sharks like I don't think it's not
him because it wouldn't make sense one
of those women on board or now or do you
think it was the woman with the glasses
or no maybe it was that guy who's on uh
on the other ship oh yeah maybe he knew
where they were and like was like no
like or it could have been the other guy
that we didn't like that blew up the
other ship when he went to the party he
could have I don't know because we
didn't really see what he was doing at
the party
don't know I feel like no one going down
in these two could have done it even
though why would they sabotage their own
ship their own like safety and going
down you put your own life at in Risk
I hope that wasn't enough foreshadowing
oh nice
nice light
hey
how is everyone so calm right now it'd
be like freaking out they're ocean
workers oh my god
oh oh yep is it gonna squish you
[Music]
no touching stuff see this is why I
wouldn't be calm for this particular
thing reason but it's so pretty down
there I understand but Megalodons are
not pretty when they're gonna eat you
hungry that sub was definitely sabotage
yeah I think it's that guy from the did
the bombs but that's my guess when the
Personnel falls on the cooler for
anything suspect we're gonna get these
sense of but we have to watch
our own backs you're probably right I
don't know well did he die though did
that thing die did he get blown up and
die it looked like it but I don't know I
feel like it was too early in the film
to get rid of the main building that's
not the yeah it would make sense that
they were like we don't want we built a
thing we never want them to discover our
thing down there
I'd say he's the first one to go well
yeah he's gonna lose that oxygen before
he even gets eaten
I say shark before oxygen
what was it uh we are we going with the
Jaws approach of not seeing if you just
fell in a hole Something's Happened to
him I know it oh boy there goes the
helmet
we have to keep moving no we
don't we he's dead honey I understand
but what are you gonna go like search
all over the place also when it's that
deep you would just die I think
immediately from the pressure
oh this is the main villain oh good he's
still alive yeah you say good I say bad
action he's gonna give us some action
it's her oh geez
she's The Saboteur so I was half right
yeah you are there's still a kilometer
to go straight through that Valley and
we don't
that's a good idea 65
oh God it's not
like it honey I'd still rather go from
Suffocation than from a Meg eat me after
huh I got a little thing keeps going in
and out stalking us
yeah okay is this a Piranha movie now
see a fish
just to show the fish
I mean they running from something
though y'all maybe 400 meters
[Music]
yeah it's so far
yeah
just stop crying and panicking that
moment right there just reminded me of
the first film where she was talking DJ
like dude calm down just relax
everybody might get to the station
they're coming over ah
oh oh those ones Oh They'll eat you up
good wait what are what are the are they
piranha what are those they're like
dinosaur fish oh they'll get you oh
oh that's tough
oh right those suits punch really hard
yeah break uh cement
okay
come on get it
nope this is not good
I think the Megs need to come and save
them so many
[Music]
oh they don't like the light yeah
basically calling for the Megs to scare
them off I don't know maybe maybe haiji
will come through for him
that reminds me of Jurassic Park
remember over here over here yeah
[Music]
oh don't tell me he's sacrificing
himself
you really want to die don't you
oh let's go come on run puppies ah
[Music]
oh
my goodness it's not too far you can
make it I don't think she's gonna make
it
this is when you just go take me this is
yeah I was gonna say that's that's a
Trope and Meg where people like to
sacrifice themselves
oh
wait did I couldn't see Diddy I don't
know just like we don't know what Jason
and mailing like no they didn't end up
ah you've got to go we don't have a
place it's coming back around
go go
come on
We're not gonna make it
good
oh
at least it's a quick death
I mean that would be so much pressure
with an explosion
getting ready for Halloween already oh
man you better watch out not put your
mouth in that water there's a dead head
exploded up in there right yep
yeah because it wasn't depressurized
when that happened yeah I'd be like I'm
gonna keep my helmet on for a minute
you read us
uh
I still don't understand what that woman
who's the villain is spending money on
them to build the underground thing that
they don't want them to find but also
put in money with Marwan like she's the
money person hopefully they will explain
that
nobody home
run in this
it's not our friend we need to contact
model one ASAP you can handle it yeah
yeah sure get it girl
what is this the demonic
whatever it is you're sending it up to
the surface with these pods
mining crystals they're using
superconductors Aerospace and Quantum
computing
this box along could be a billion
dollars oh mine in for fine gems
you're alive
I was going over the video of when you
went over that station before looks like
emergency escape paths
oh they can use those I bet you that
lady's going to be like how do you
expect me to pay for Mar 1 without me
illegally mining Jewels at the bottom of
the ocean
these are my designs how do they have
this
it's a job
think about who could get that stuff in
there you know figure it out
on three three
come on Jason Statham could do that by
himself please mailing's gonna figure it
out she's gonna be like here you go
turn the key press it still I know Jason
Statham could still do that on his own I
don't buy it no it's really a good thing
she came along they really wouldn't have
figured that out
close the hat on
it that wasn't me we need to talk
handedly I have full control of the
station and I block down this room oh
she's working with the lady three of our
friends are dead because of you
it's the first Escape pod
save me
Jonas in the heart why he's barely done
anything but give him a wink to be like
fake it
or they can do a fake at like you said
yeah you should do it also too easy
[Music]
he's gonna say he's got 18 ABS he'll
survive we'll be back at work in a week
using your technology to take whatever
we want
chewing up the scenery
yeah
teacher finish this
yes stupid ecosystem it's all about the
money
if we could capture coming to the
surface mailing will figure it out she
knows computer stuff I'm telling you if
I were them I would have just told them
what they want to hear go back and then
you do what you do to them
5 30
60 seconds before he passes out all
right buddy he's gonna do it
all right now shut off the flooding mate
I will say even though I said he looked
bored in this film as an uh as an actor
he's really doing a good job filling the
surrogate father role like you really do
feel a connection between yeah not only
that but like the passage of time
between films that they've had with each
other yeah I agree
foreign
that wasn't a Meg that was the other
thing okay
oh boy I think it's been 30 seconds did
you do it
oh he's about to pass out oh I think he
did it uh you did it right oh God yeah
tough did he get in there this is like
an acid trip oh my God let him out you
don't you don't remember me do you
there's a million scumbags in this world
I saw they keep track of all of them
yes there we go let's get into it I was
gonna say like fighting a human being is
so like nonchalant for him after
fighting megalodons yeah it's like this
is nothing
yeah buddy yeah
oh there we go this is how they get
turned into minerals the rocks
yeah
oh God I felt that one
nice
right at the oh the nick of time ooh
come on buddy you could do it yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
hit the red button hit it
okay I'm not a doctor but how are you
still getting up after those metal shots
to the face oh are they gonna just
disable the risk cover the truth like
she could be repairing it right but not
wait
the truth shall set you free or piss you
off we'll never make it past the Megs we
need the destruction let up the station
to Max without a tuck it and kill us
nothing we're fast enough are we doing
the mag thing of sacrificing or so what
are we doing here
so it seems like they're having them
attack the baseball they ship out
no he's not oh no
Jonas like waiting like he didn't have
to in the first movie
facing your demons of waiting not
waiting
it's like hey waiting work this time
it's a hole in the thermal there oh yes
oh they're gonna be able to escape yeah
you will see that eventually
I mean I'm a dumb dumb but is there a
way to fix the whole or no way
time
what is that is that like a
like a octopus yeah well didn't we see
one in the first movie yeah I just
forgot about it
how are you escaping oh smart
and how are you not in ultra pain from
the metal shots you took I don't want to
harm you but I do need you to come out
of
[Music]
I love it I love it do it
yes oh God no come on really really no
you did not that really hurts yourself
in the eye buddy you're smarter than
that I don't like that right pepper
sprayed himself right accident I just
saw him go up with the taser and I'm
like I thought he pepper sprayed himself
accidentally what does it say
um terrorist action yeah good too
I love peace too yeah
oh did DJ
where did that come from I love it oh my
God nice
oh my god oh
I'm not gonna lie that might have been
my favorite moment in both films
after the first film I'm taking karate
lessons or Kung Fu whatever whatever
style of fighting that was that was
awesome I trained up I learned how to
fight I learned how to swim and I'll
never go anywhere without my survival
package yeah I'm glad you learned how to
train even though I don't know what
could that would have been with the oh
wow
yeah I even made poison tip bullets just
like Jaws too yeah yeah wait poison tip
bullets just oh yeah yeah and Jaws to uh
Roy shatter's character did have he shot
him into the ocean and then it was a
blue School of Bluefish and he scared
the the he scared the beach goers oh
that gun's in your face though dang it
that was some unfortunate back
there I love to show so much
that was great cool
DJ just sat on him I love that
are you okay
it took uh some shots to the face we
need to lock this place down now as he
have no marks on him nothing though guys
looks like the Megs are here we've got a
big problem
yeah
three of them
it's from the thermocline breach but you
can relax this place
Meg proof I was also thinking
just with one little punch it's so easy
we paddle out slow no engines minimal
motion it won't look like food I still
think we look like food I just stay away
from water or find them and once you
escape like after the first movie too
let's not bring them back alive
you do know how to draw this thing right
you guys oh yay you look like food now
dummies stop the engine right now
attractive mess I want to see him get it
at the shot take it
what do you want me to do fix it kill
them
you're the most generic villains ever
yeah we have to find a way to warn
people in case the max move towards land
there's nylon 60 clicks sausage of us
it's listed as inhabited for an island
where they say oh okay like fun party
people oh this does look fun oh I want
to go to fun Island it's about to be
scary Island but y'all need to comment
and let me know a fun Island really
exists because I need to go to there
yeah and where it is too is it is
OMG and yes I know people Pippin is a
reference to the first Jaws movie Pippin
the dog I know I missed that reference
stay out of the water oh it is Pippin
it's Pippin yeah hey don't let pip in
the water please he survived the first
film come on
get out of here Pippin knows the dog
always knows
oh he's gonna okay oh we propose are we
proposing
I know it's a nice ring though she's
gonna say yes put it on and get eaten by
Meg immediately I feel like that's about
to happen
oh no
find it it just dropped honey
oh boy
you fall in the water yeah she went bye
bye bye Meg but nobody heard it
apparently yeah
oh God it scares me
oh my God
whoa
really doing the whole Alfred hitchcocky
and just oh it's the octopus
[Music]
they're like we're at fun Island we're
not getting off the beach
whoa what's happening here oh is it the
dinosaur lizards is it yeah it must be
you guys yeah it is
are we gonna see another Tyrannosaurus
or is I wish
ah the noises
oh my God I'd be freaking out oh my
goodness
whoa
yeah that is such a cool shot though
that shot that was amazing
is my the helicopter in my pull down
sunny
no I want the helicopter shot oh yeah no
it's not why can't I get my helicopter
shot this lady she's gonna wander you
are really dumb you just told your
helicopter pilot to get out of the
helicopter and go chat
I can't I was like really she's gonna
get eaten by a lizard Dino it's gonna be
great yes she is you called it
[Music]
that reminds me of uh Newman from
Seinfeld and uh oh my God they're going
up
that was satisfying though that was good
I did not like her much unless she got
it in here emergency stuff
really
I mean that is a good thing to have in
case of an emergency he ain't wrong
this stuff is as powerful as TNT
oh from those creature things lizard
things
come on
oh my God that one got me
let's go
oh my God girl really
hey because all of you together up
against the wall
uh
uh put those rappers down oh you'll do
what
yeah but aren't they gonna get in there
with you with you guys too yeah
ah those things are
[Music]
oh oh you just missed it oh man it's
like jousting you gotta You Gotta Get
Right There
whoa
okay now now do it
looks awesome damn
that's cool
goodbye
one down two to go
foreign
[Music]
oh yes nice we gotta go
oh God that reminds me of the
Velociraptors and Lost World Jurassic
Park when they run through the grass gas
we need that
that's filling up really quickly
that's smart if you can get up and fuel
or don't let it fill up y'all barely got
any oh boy
oh
no oh my gosh no
light them on fire
oh
they have a lighter on them oh flare gun
yeah they'll light them on fire
they're really good at improvising
no what why are you shooting at him when
he's going after a Megalodon my God this
guy like let him let him kill the
Megalodon first and then go ahead and
take him out if you want
words making
she is so brave
oh no the octopus the helicopter
no Jason's gonna have to get her I
wanted the helicopter oh but you're
you're doing this is not the helicopter
I wanted to go down
no sacrificing
no not Cliff Curtis dang it did he get
off uh maybe he'll survive uh
whoa whoa damn
whoa
damn that reminded me of Quint going
falling down the ship in the Orca and
the first Jaws
dude you are so getting eaten and I
cannot wait
yeah
hand to hand man how many shots to the
face has this guy taken nothing hurts
him
oh blood yep there you go uh oh
he's such a badass yeah you couldn't do
it
that was cool what she's gonna come back
next scene and be fine
oh no traffic
come on chop it
in the Box thing yeah
whoa all right nice catch
holy to Molly that thing's huge
yeah but wasn't that supposed to be for
the Meg
or one of them eggs
oh buddy
[Music]
oh saved ya
is it hygiene
oh oh whoa whoa no way
is this like a mega OCTA yeah I mean
those aren't oh I guess I got it ah yeah
nope we thought you had it but yeah I
thought it did too
damn
it's like that was my master from
earlier in the film how dare you if
anyone will eat my master it's me
oh it's making noise oh
is he gonna cut it open with that I
remember he did that in the first oh
nice
get the blade going I don't know how you
picked that up but then again you're
Jason stake so I believe in you oh oh
make noise with it that's what Roy
Scheider did in Jaws too he was making
noise as a distraction
I assume that's a shallow
yeah I think that's a shallows reference
ah yes yes
oh that's that zombie eye going uh-oh
oh nice
oh no you don't get him DJ right yeah DJ
is such a badass Nice Shot buddy
no it's okay so listen to me let's
spread out he's gonna be like no I
trained her I got this no I feel like
hygiene might listen I don't know if it
is her maybe she would I mean do you
think the shark did save him from that
squid octopus thing because I feel like
oh yeah see now she knows
oh yeah oh she's like it's okay I know
you
oh I still don't trust it I don't really
either but maybe yeah
sometimes there's a situation and bad
things are happening and you just have
to get involved I'm proud of you good
job where are you what about haichi
she's still out there maybe pregnant ah
preferably not oh she's definitely
pregnant it's looking looks like
Survival Island except for what is this
the shark nobody went over
there it's like we'll take any amount of
money to survive Island
oh man
all right
okay
this one
okay all right Meg two the trench yeah I
mean it was good it was fun I didn't
like it as much as the first one with
you on that yeah I mean I mean how what
are your first like what's your first
thoughts okay well just because we like
to be positive around here
um I still think the strength because
for me the biggest strength of the first
film definitely fun in in that aspect
obviously turn your brain off type of
film
um same thing here turn your brain off
type of film but I think the biggest
strength of the first film was like the
relationship between Su Yen and her
daughter and then also Jason Statham
coming in like the bond ship that he has
with uh the three of them
I really like the role that Jason Eve
again I know I made that comment that he
kind of looks bored in this film but I
really do like that surrogate father
role that he takes up in the film yeah
with mailings yeah with mailing it was
it was really yeah thing sorry excuse me
uh I really do like it it was really
sweet and Deering and like I really did
buy the the history in between films
that they had had and obviously uh with
the uh the encounter that they had from
the first film like I really did buy it
and yeah it was really sweet and I just
enjoyed all their scenes all their
interactions I I love their chemistry
the two actors they really you know I
couldn't take my eyes off the screen
whenever they were you know on the
screen together and uh I really did feel
invested when and scared for them when
even though I had a feeling they were
gonna survive I didn't think they were
going to take her out in the movie or
Jason Statham either and I I always felt
like he had a good shot of surviving
against the shark or whoever he was
facing but still I always felt invested
and and worried for them and the stakes
were high whenever those two are on
screen yeah and again staying on the
positive I love what they did with DJ in
this film yeah again I loved him in the
first film he always had the the logic
in the sense like what are we doing in
this situation get out of the way
whatever you always had logic and sense
and then again in this film like getting
like that one scene where he had the
fighting in the tremble where did that
come from comedic relief and that is
great oh my God we're I mean and then I
still really love Cliff Curtis as well
he was he was a blast as well a joy to
watch so the chemistry between that and
I like the uncle too I thought he did a
good job I personally would have loved
if they would have kept suyen in this
and even with the uncle I still think
they could have made it work again I'm
not a writer I don't know how you know
wood probably would have been tough to
figure out a way to find a way to do all
those characters but still yeah I really
did like suyen from the first film so I
wish they would have found a way to do
that but I think the reason he probably
likes sui and wanted her back this movie
didn't have as much heart as the first
one it lost the heart even though like
Jason and May Ying when they were on
screen they had a really great
relationship and that was really cute
but we didn't get to see any really much
of the foundation being built unless
you're just remembering one yeah so I
think a lot of the heart was taken out
versus in one I was like I got close to
crying when the dad died and then uh you
know and then they had to tell May Ying
about it in the first one it was just
sad people there was just a little more
heart in it where they had to bond over
these like life experience and be like
we gotta find Megalodon and also s-h-i-t
is going down versus this one there was
still a lot of stuff going on and I like
to see the payoff with May Ying of being
like she's smart she was raised by her
mom she knows stuff like she's in there
kind of saving them like yeah they
brought her along but I I felt like the
payoff with the with her and her new dad
I would have liked to see more of them
kind of in the beginning of maybe more
of a relationship so that the ending was
even sweeter I don't know exactly how
they maybe could have done that with
um her and the uncle and Jason
um but I do think like that moment at
the end when they're like absolutely
meaning they come together to tell her
you're still grounded is a way of the
script bringing it which could have had
I think a better payoff as like these
are her new parents now but it didn't
give me as many of like the heart feels
as the first one for sure and I'm all
about those those like heart feels but
this was still a blast we got to see a
mega octopus a bunch of Megalodons and
like use some cool cool stuff I would
also add my other one positive Pippin oh
yeah and Pippin survived that's also a
positive
um for negative the fact that Mae Yang
saved yet again from the ocean Pippen's
got to survive every time that has to be
a call back to each and every one no for
sure and uh like I said I I of course
forgot uh which I already mentioned
during the reaction but just in case it
got cut out uh Pippin was a reference to
the first Jaws film where Pippin the dog
was uh in that film in the shark off
screen took out Pippin which the shirt
the dog did not survive sorry yeah well
sorry to all of us but um yeah no I'm
glad that the dog survived in both films
good job by the writers but uh bad job
on the writers in my opinion with the
villains in this film I thought they
were so I actually did like even though
he was a piece of crap uh Rayne Wilson's
character was funny in the first film
but made dumb decisions especially going
out where he you know got eaten by the
shark I thought he made a really dumb
decision there but there were stuff
about him where I just found him again
he was hilarious and
um I just found myself relating to
certain things about his character he
was a more fun Village it was definitely
more fun whereas the villains here I'm
like they're so generic and I'm like I
can't wait to see them get eaten totally
100 I mean I didn't really believe her
the main villain and then the blonde
girl that she hired yeah so was dating
the Man villain yeah all of those three
villains I didn't really believe that
much not at all acting wise it seemed
like it might have been the direction
I'm not sure that it seemed very much
like what are you doing we're here to
get the gems uh not that bad but you get
you get what I'm saying versus like when
Jason Statham delivers a line even
though it may be overly dramatic like
whatever that one line was like they're
coming and get us I don't know what it
is but I always believe him versus those
three villains and maybe that was on
purpose yes that they felt uh very uh
they didn't feel as grounded it felt
like when they would deliver something
it felt just like the payoff wasn't
really there but
um I mean obviously we had to have them
there she's she's like I have a bunch of
dollars to build these these ships that
go way down but I'm not doing it for
research I'm doing it for Jim and again
this is not like yeah and I'm sure
they're all competent actors I have not
seen any of those three and anything
else no no yeah yes I'm sure only just
yes yeah yeah and I mean could be
Direction could be the writing of course
yeah and again this is more on the
writing now when it comes to the main uh
woman villain like why did you go go to
the island first of all that made no
sense to me and then when you're about
to leave you hear a noise or something
why did you tell your helicopter pilot
to go out and go and check yeah get out
yeah leave like I get it the writers
learn how to fly a helmet lady I mean I
get it that the writer's like well I
have to come up with a way to kill her
off so but that's the dumbest thing ever
well they could have I mean the little
the the dinosaur lizards could have just
eaten both of them right away right
because that guy ran off yeah ever came
back or you could have had the shark
just jump into the sky and rip it oh
yeah he's missing his shark with the
helicopter yeah you did it with the okay
look thank you for doing what the
octopus but was with Cliff Curtis and
you know I would have rather it wasn't
the right helicopter it was the Wonder
one he's gonna be whining about it for
the next month she's gonna have to hear
about it and so are you guys we don't we
mean it I'm just gonna be like block his
number We're not gonna talk or do a
reaction for the next month which is
only going to be like she wears my
helicopter when she unblocks me she's
gonna text her are you ready to not talk
about that or do I have to block her are
you over it yet buddy because I feel
like we need to get over it yeah but
overall look I I again I don't think I
think you said it best I don't think
this had and again the first one wasn't
the greatest film ever it was a fun time
I just had more but it had more it for
sure had more heart than this but having
said that I still really enjoyed the the
scenes between uh and and uh Jonas yeah
Jonas uh Jason say them I still really
enjoyed those scenes and I still like
the camaraderie and the chemistry
between Cliff Curtis DJ and even the
uncle I thought he did a really good job
the actor who played him
um and the five of them I thought they
all did and even the uh I forgot the
actress who played the the character was
she did a pretty good job as well yeah I
thought they all did it you know the
payoff of DJ learning a bunch of stuff
like I learned from the first one yeah I
learned how
to learn hi and bring weapons and bring
we didn't get to see him use the the
poison darts oh no no he did did he he
did yeah remember he he shot at the the
lizard thing oh he did okay yeah I would
have loved to have seen it on a Meg but
he did get to shoot he did get to shoot
the lizard you're right dragging
whatever those things were yeah and I
like that he used the mirror thing to
call back to a bunch of films whatever
but like I just love how how he upped
his game which was super fun also his
like roundhouse kick I was like uh that
looked awesome like no stun double for
you sir yeah no they weren't cutting
they they went wide shot and no cut I
was like good for you man but it was an
awesome reveal that you wouldn't expect
it was like this is awesome
like after the even though you can't
really apply those skills to um
Megalodon shark still it would make
sense after the events of the first film
okay I gotta learn stuff yeah I mean and
you could with those poison darts I
don't know yeah for sure yeah uh also
you know a little disappointed we didn't
get to see the 18 ABS that might still
be stuck on Jason's stuff he's got him I
mean it's not necessary but a little bit
just for a little bit come on now
Statham there's still time for something
the first one they'll do it in the third
film they're like we're only doing them
on odd number films don't worry oh
really all right well well we know that
we know that other shark is still out
there and she's probably gonna give
birth most likely because they we saw a
little scene there we're amazing and you
called that the whole thing so we're
gonna have more Megs out there which is
good I mean by that time make three I
mean Mae Ying is gonna be like a full-on
teenager or maybe a young adult who can
drink who knows how long it's gonna take
but I'm gonna rate it out of ten I would
give this like I'd give it like a 6.5 I
was thinking six points like 6.5 because
it was still a lot of fun I love seeing
them I mean who doesn't the Megalodons
when they're on screen and Mal's just
like eating all these people I mean I
don't want people to die in real life
you guys get what I mean it just looks
it looks so awesome yeah and yeah I
would say probably 6.5 as well okay yeah
so there we go what was your favorite
part
oh
um I would say my favorite part was the
DJ reveal with his skills that was that
was the greatest moment ever yeah and
surviving it's uh those two yes I I I
was gonna say I liked the cut making
saving pip and that was a lot of fun but
um DJ's reveal was great I don't know
what was my favorite part oh God you
guys oh ah
um
uh Under Pressure yeah I don't know I
was gonna say like when he went into the
plane I was like that was cool but
that's at the top of the film I would
just say anytime the magazine something
I can't really think of a big thing from
this one I mean I asked you the question
when the woman the main woman villain
gets you and that was so satisfying I'll
give you that one that was good that was
good I was glad to be whatever you know
I mean I feel like that's it my uh my my
yeah 6.5 I liked it it's good the Meg is
good it's always good we always want to
see Megalodon on screen especially if
Jason Statham is there just next time
maybe shows your 18 ABS again please sir
that's the problem with this film
yeah man 18 absolutely not back still
love me Ying I hope she comes back for
many many more and I mean you guys can
comment and tell us what you feel like
the juice is what's the juice that we
miss what's the stuff that we I don't
know tell us what movie we should watch
next just tell us honestly what life is
I'm gonna be honest with you because uh
life it's like I sometimes I feel like
that shark who looked real rough like
he's been through 18 mores I feel like
that sometimes so like your advice of
being like do this thing I might take it
you know because we love you guys I
think that's it any last thoughts Andrew
no just uh excited for uh whatever we
react to next yeah
we love you so much that
end of the May o me too the trench bye
foreign